harry and megan were due to attend a
charity event in london but a source
tells et that harry went to balmoral
flying solo while megan the duchess of
sussex stayed behind queen elizabeth ii
was the rock on which modern britain was
built britain
is the great country it is today because
of her it's understood that the family
wanted prince harry to be there even
though he was unable to get to balmoral
in time to see his grandmother
but megan the duchess of sussex
was not we understand invited to join
the family um she has said she will go
to balmoral at another time but i think
it is quite significant that prince
harry traveled to balmoral on his own
without his wife the duke of cambridge
flew to aberdeen as quickly as he could
leaving kate behind of course this was
prince george princess charlotte and
prince louise first day at school so she
made the very difficult decision to stay
behind to be there to collect the
children and princess anne was on the
ground and the prince of wales and
camilla were over at dunfry's house and
traveled across to balmoral and it is my
understanding that the prince of wales
was with the queen
while she passed away i think the
pictures that we saw of family members
arriving at balmoral really said it all
this is a family in mourning now and of
course
the queen was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother i think it is quite
telling that prince harry traveled solo
to balmoral he took we understand a
flight on his own and he was not
accompanied by the duchess of sussex i
think that is deeply significant that
megan was not invited to join the family
by the queen's bedside the rift between
william and harry is a rift that has run
deep we know it is a rift that's caused
the queen a great deal of pain
and the brothers will be together at
balmoral this is the first time they
have been together and really since the
duke of edinburgh's funeral nearly 18
months ago
will there be a reconciliation i think
at the moment it's difficult to tell but
i do think this is a family who will now
be united in grief and harry is in
balmoral i think the decision was made
for megan not to be there probably to
make this very difficult and what will
be a highly emotional family reunion
possibly easier for the rest of the
family
you